ils nous ont fait rêver mais l'aventure
en Coupe du monde s'arrête en quart de
finale pour les rugbyman français
desfites 28- 29 hier soir au Stade de
France face au springbx dans un match
d'une rare intensité une immense
déception pour les près de
3000 supporteur tour enjo de la Fan Zone
du stade tonley à tour donc on retiendra
l'ambiance comme toujours au rendez-vous
pendant cette Coupe du monde en chaple
yta un point Sare la France de l'Afrique
du Sud il ne reste qu secondes de match
et l'écran du ST ton coupe au pire des
[Musique]
moments les supporters tourangeau loupe
la dernière action l'équipe de France de
rugby s'incline 28 à 29 et n'ira pas en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde les
200800 spectateurs de la Fan Zone
tourangel sont
dépités la France estiné pour un petit
point on aurait pu la gagner celle-ci
mais elle nous est passé à rien du
tout on est tous déçus ici il a pas
manqué grandchose il a manqué un point
il a pas manqué grandchose jug mal jugé
par non ouais l'arbitrage était pas
exceptionnel tout s'est joué au dernier
moment mais
bon la soirée va pas se finir comme on
l'aurait prévu
[Musique]
80 minutes plusutôt l'ambiance est
diamétralementosé ent défite au SPR est
[Musique]
inenvisable qu'on est plutôt bien après
l'arbitre nous a pas accordé quelques
pénalités bon je suis un peu chifon sur
ça
mais je sens bien c'est serrme on est
meilleur on est
est j'ai confiance c'est le 15 de France
c'est c'est laance mettre le je en place
tout va très bien se passer malgré la
défaite des Bleus cette soirée a au
moins permis au tourangeau d'oublier un
instant la lourdeur de l'actualité
nationale et
internationale